la politique de testing de test et de
ces fameux tests pcr qui permettent de
dire vous êtes porteur du virus
pour vous dire quand les les chiffres
changent tout le temps mais quand les
allemands avaient fait plus de deux
millions de tests les français en
étaient encore à 450 milles c'est
presque d'ailleurs cette différence de 1
à 4 dont je parlais si vous testez vous
allez bien mais parce que vous testez
quelqu'un qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
ça ne guérit pas un malade du coc vide
je vais pas moins mourir parce que vous
me tester bien sûr je suis d'accord mais
si vous me tester si je vous teste et
que vous vous savez que vous êtes vous
venez vous avez une petite tout un
quelque chose de très grave
vous avez une petite toux et vous venez
pour vous faire tester dans un pays on
vous teste dans l'autre on vous dit vous
rentrez chez vous vous avez pas vous
revenez pas d'un pays d'endémie on va
pas vous tester dans l'autre on vous
teste on vous teste et on dit désolé
monsieur taddei vous êtes porteur du
virus
ça va durer si vous avez tellement peu
de symptômes que vous allez le reste est
porteur cinq ou six jours mais on vous
propose tout allait dans un hôtel de
confinement tout seul
vraiment vous n'allez pas être en
contact avec vos proches ou alors si
vous avez la possibilité de rester chez
vous bien calfeutré et que personne ne
vous ne vous approche de trop près sans
protection
alors c'est possible si on vous dit cela
est-ce que franchement vous pensez pas
que vous même vous allez faire très
attention que chez vous conservez un peu
comme un pestiféré pendant quelques
jours on n'aura pas envie de vous
approcher voudrais pas très appétissant
bref on va s'auto confiné de façon
beaucoup beaucoup plus efficace si l'on
est dans la connaissance que l'on est
porteur du virus que si on n'est pas
dans cette connaissance et je pense que
on a négligé beaucoup trop l'impact
qu'avait la valeur du test sur la
vraiment la fracture des chaînes de
transmission
on a réussi à rompre en allemagne en
autriche en suisse beaucoup plus de
chaînes de transmission qu'on a réussi à
le faire en france jusqu'à présent
[Musique]